bull est strié dahlia orchidées une
compression florales inspirent et de
césar le célèbre sculpteur à chaumont
sur loire les fleurs sont des oeuvres
d'art des oeuvres vivante dont le parfum
embaument toutes les pièces du château
ici c'est la salle à manger qui
accueille un foisonnement de couleurs
on a fait un travail et si très
renaissance c'est à dire que on a fait
une profusion fleurs là on voit
majoritairement ce qu'on a voulu
travailler en premier ce sont les roses
donc évidemment à chaumont aux deux
jardins principalement les variétés
comme prince jardinier julietta edun qui
est la dernière dans la salle de billard
cet autre artiste a voulu une
composition plus poétique
je me suis inspiré donc de la venue de
deux astrologue important au château qui
sont donc ruggeri et nostradamus et je
me suis dit que je pouvais peut-être
créer quelque chose qui évoque les
astres et donc de monter au dessus du
billard une structure qui puisse un peu
élevé la vision vers les cieux quand
fleurir est un art une exposition qui
rappelle aussi le lien très fort qui a
toujours entretenu chaumont sur loire
avec le végétal l'art floral est un art
à part entière et au fond je trouve
qu'il n'est pas suffisamment valorisé
les intervenants dont on voit les
réalisations sont des artistes pour
certains mondialement reconnus sont
comme des peintres qui joue avec la
matière
floral avec la couleur avec les formes
avec et parfois également l'art floral
un art éphémère qui a trouvé au château
de catherine de médicis un écrin parfait
pour s'épanouir